for example you know I remember my first
show at the sports bar it went horrible
you know just five minutes later yeah
and one guy came up to me and said hey I
think you're probably funny but I don't
understand what you're saying
oh damn I know but yeah he was an Asian
guy too
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
today we have a special guest Mr Joe
Wong
so much it's a good pleasure to be here
and thank you so much for having me and
uh yeah I just feel very special today
you know I was I was pretty excited when
you were on the roster and then I
messaged Bart and I was like hey is that
the stand-up comedian Joe Wong and then
he's like yeah that's him and I'm like
oh my God because I first saw you I
think you're at the White House or
something oh yeah yeah the White House
yeah but I didn't leave the bag of
cocaine
some other guy
that had to be like 2016 20 actually
that's 2010. 2010 I know yeah yeah okay
wow yeah because I remember watching
that and going oh dude like he's funny
clean comedy but he's able to like hit
all the the stuff and I was just like
that's a really good well-rounded
comedian and then um yeah I would see
your videos pop up once in a while yeah
yeah yeah that's some people get
confused they saw the video they were
like
is this Joe Biden why is it so young
yeah that's what I thought when I saw it
a real yeah because because there is a
conspiracy theory going around saying
that the Biden we see right now is a
clone of himself you heard about this
yeah I know it sounds ridiculous but
well it's kind of a shitty clone
they're still working out the Kinks oh
yeah I know
uh 20 years wow I know I know yeah what
got you into it oh I I just you know I'm
just interested in humor and I used to
work in biotech you know I never got the
promotion and stuff I figured oh I
should try something else probably
how did you go from biotech to Comedy
same thing yeah you just gradually get
into it you know I I oh actually I took
a stand-up comedy class
yeah what even got you because that that
to me still so
comedy's here standard comedy class is
still here there's still a lot of gaps
up there yeah wait a minute your hand
gesture is the opposite from a lot of
Asian parents
please prepare us like about chemistry
comedy
not in this room
yeah how did you even take a class or
even like know to look for a class
especially 20 years ago yeah basically
uh one of one of my co-workers took me
to a stand-up comedy show it was uh the
first comedian I saw was Seymour
Phillips
and uh I don't know if you guys know him
he's no he's really good comic you know
he does a lot of
uh really weird humor that he used to no
actually he just toured with uh weird
owl this year oh okay yeah oh that's
that style yes I love his similar sense
of humor you know they got along really
well they used to have a TV show
together and they just toured Europe
this year but anyway but he somehow he
does this weird voice and he has this uh
hair that's dyed white you know hanging
from one side but when I saw him in
Houston he wasn't doing any of those he
just sits on stage in his normal voice
and tell jokes you know one after
another it was just so good you know I
was like wow I was like oh I wish I
could stand the punch lines you know
you didn't know English that well back
then or well that's the thing I know
English quite well but then I don't
understand the punch lines because I
hear every word fine and I I understand
all the setup but none of the punches
yeah the and but I still I understand
some of it so I was like wow this is
great and then my company is folded in
Houston so I moved to Boston when you're
in a new city you just want to try
something new I figure oh you know I
tried you know some golf some you know
shooting you know but then none of them
stuck you know he's like
it's not for me
so I just looked into some I saw an
Advertiser before a comedy class so I
just use other curiosity I went there
and that's the first time I learned that
humor can be learned and trained you
know yeah because I always assume all
the funny people were born that way
Chris is ridiculous no no baby came out
that woman they're just really happy
yeah
everyone just made his son oh really
natural comedian
from a baby more like a prankster yeah
oh I see he's developing he's developing
natural go-to thing just by himself in
the corner his favorite thing it was
like he has this plastic Pizza yeah and
he would go like this yeah whoa whoa
whoa it didn't fall he put the pizza on
his face and like it was just already
just doing like three stooges physical
comedy just by himself and he's just
practicing yeah like you're not
performing for anyone or I'm just
watching him like what the heck is he
doing but you should do your tape it I
have it oh yeah wow that's amazing
so many times I wish I taped my son
doing stuff you know but you know he's
already 16 too late
you can start taping them now oh yeah
but he's a teenager now you know he got
really annoyed
so the comedy class was actually good
yeah I learned a lot of Basics you know
I didn't even know you know like a joke
has a setup and punchline before that so
it was a stand-up comedy course yeah and
then they helped you with structure and
oh yeah yeah and also uh from the chorus
I know a bunch of people who start
around the same time so there's some
camaraderie there you know like for
example you know I remember my first
show at the sports bar it went horrible
you know it's just five minutes later
yeah and one guy came up to me and said
hey I think you're probably funny but I
don't understand what you're saying
I know but and he was an Asian guy too
he's like sorry but still yeah because
uh but then I really noticed that none
of my other classmates are doing well so
I feel slightly better that's why you
need someone to start around the same
time you know and also uh they came from
different walks of life it's that's kind
of interesting to me too you know we
have you know lawyers
uh uh patent guy advertisement people
and one guy who runs a uh a hardware
store yeah he's just everyone that just
hates their job
you're a biotech
engulfing and shooting didn't work
but you know but looking back some of
the guys even though they're really new
I just remember some of them are really
good right off the bat and I was just I
remember one guy he told this joke I
could we still remember the guy
basically said oh I went to my grandma's
place this Sunday uh I think she was
using her vibrator
because he was dry
so horrible but then you think of myself
well that kind of makes sense did you
after after you didn't do so well what
made you want to like keep going well
that's the thing that's like telling
jokes and then no one laughing is like
one of the worst feelings in the world
yeah that's why I think
my uh experience is uh
if you start with a group of 20 you
usually have one or two people left
after half a year it's just so
frustrating yeah including the guy who
wrote the joke I just told yeah just
doesn't do anymore yeah yeah this is
most people just quit but then that's
what I'm saying to people if you do
something and you you fail but you still
want to do it then that might be your
calling you know yeah you just have to
so you failed but you you still enjoyed
it and you wanted to keep going so
that's the that's what probably
separated you is what you're saying uh
yeah I don't enjoy feeling though
every time I have bad show I'm like oh I
suck you know it just makes me feel bad
for like days yeah but then couple of
days later you still want to climb up
and go back to the clubs and tell jokes
you know so
I guess that's how is the pay change
from biochemistry oh my God
falling off a cliff
[Laughter]
you know I got paid fairly what like
middle class type of salary when I was
in biotech but instead of Comedy I
didn't make a dime for the first five
years
geez what'd you do I just live off
savings or whether you're like a waiter
or no I just basically go to work during
the day and tell jokes at night yeah
yeah and you I can't even get stage time
because you know it's pretty competitive
this business so if the club owner knows
you're a new guy they just usually don't
give you any spot
uh so you just sit there and wait yeah
you sometimes I go to the comedy club
and wait you know that's why sometimes
and then you finally get the 12 o'clock
crowd when they're all drunk oh yeah
you're in the B room yeah or in the
basement of a motel you know that kind
of thing yeah a lot of those
yeah but sometimes yeah that's why
people sometimes joke out you're you're
not a stand-up comedian you're a standby
comedian yeah
but you have to put in the time and
that's the I still find it very tough
here in Los Angeles because um in
basically every other City you know it
stage time is pretty fairly easy for me
even even in Australia you know I just
came back from a tour of uh Australia
New Zealand I go to the city I basically
email the booker a hit a day or two a
hand you know I can't pretty much get
some stage time but not in Los Angeles
that's just really there's so many
comedians here so many comedians also
I'm really new in town and also this
town values
celebrities way more than standout
comedians yeah because you know if you
go to like New York it's very different
that people still value content more so
so you mean that celebrities are getting
stand-up comedian stage time oh yeah
yeah oh so like at the comedy clubs here
like Laugh Factory or any of them Comedy
Store if there's a celebrity that wants
to do stand-up comedy oh yeah
interesting everybody has to cut their
time you know the celebrity has to go in
and do their sense and the celebrity is
also standing up comedian too right or
no uh it doesn't have to you don't have
to be yeah yeah it's like it's like
influencers here too oh yeah they let
daylight influencers have stage time
here like if Logan Paul showed up
they're like oh yeah let's give him the
mic I mean half as famous as him even
wow wow yeah because he makes sense
because he's big yeah that's crazy
firstly you have to factor in the
networking like if you just know
somebody oh yeah yeah it's a very yeah
especially in in La it's all about you
know how you hang with people you know
it's very different
um because when I started doing stand up
I was uh 32. you know I have a you know
family I have a mortgage I have to worry
about all these stuff yeah basically I
go in and do my comedy and just get out
you know I don't see the network oh
you're not going to the bar after and
hanging out yeah yeah because that's why
you know
they used to call me the Comedy Ninja
because I just go into myself
I know what you haven't heard the most
recent part yet okay I can't wait no who
really want to hear this
oh one one of the racist kid was
actually an Asian dude you know we did
the show in the basement and I I think
he's probably some kind of Asian college
kid he's sitting in the front room
and he just started to do these awful
Asian accent oh
just heckling while you were doing
yourself I know yeah I was like what if
he just talks like that and he's just he
just got here from China and you're like
you
I can I can tell a real accent from fake
one you know but just oh man and he's
also an issue because I was like okay
I'm gonna let this go it was just so
awful because you know other comedians
are like oh man I wish I could go over
and beat him up I'm like
yeah but then
you
now we say this word like eternalized
racism more now but at the time there's
not even a term for it you know that's
just like yeah let's I guess the kid
thought it was funny I guess not so much
did everybody laugh when he did it
though oh no everybody just feels so
awkward he didn't kill yeah he's killing
it
I I was there to try to memorize my
jokes
does your kid think you're funny oh
probably was it a tough crowd yeah he's
a teenager yeah I know every teenager
thinks their dad's lame I know yeah yeah
I I totally appreciate that
I I am lame though because you know I
sometimes I just feel that
I'm just nothing about me sticks out you
know like I remember sometimes like uh
you know like newspaper reporter will
come to my house they take some pictures
of me I feel like there's nothing
special
I know
can you pause
oh yeah
give me angry face
happy face
that's her because some like most like
celebrities or comedians there's like a
theme about them oh yeah and they can
kind of like hone in on that thing like
yeah top yeah but you forget you're just
okay
alligator yeah yeah
are you are you still in BIO uh are you
still in that oh no no so when did you
make the uh transition into becoming a
full-time Entertainer oh uh that was
after the the White House gig oh so that
one oh really skyrocketed the actually
it was before that you know I got a lot
of coverage but after that sometimes I
go to work and we have a stack of uh
Wall Street Journal and I'm on the front
page oh wow yeah it's like
yeah oh I pretend I didn't see and then
walk to my office and
and I used to work for this company
that's kind of the largest corporation
in Europe and from this second or third
largest in the world is the
pharmaceutical company
nobody knows me and it's a big hierarchy
but after that you know when they have
board meetings they will come to my
office to the first and chat and chat a
little bit
so all the executives
executive and then I I of course you
know I'm gonna chat a little bit but I
have no idea who they are
I got more out of town gigs so I just
have to uh quit the day job in them what
what brought you to the West Coast oh
because that's where you stay now right
yeah yeah
it's a complicated you know
yeah my son's going to school here you
know and my manager is here too you know
so I figured I'd give this place a try
you know yeah also you're new to this
area oh it's very new I just moved here
you know like January this year
whoa sweet yeah yeah how do you like all
the Asian food the proximity to all the
Asian food oh I can't complain
where are you moving from uh
Beijing yeah from China oh damn yeah I
just I did like comedy for 10 years
there oh you started there oh no no I
started in Boston oh I was gonna say
because I was like 10 years of Beijing
jokes yeah
it's hard being a comedian out there huh
in Chinese can you do stand-up comedy in
Chinese too oh yeah yeah wow so do you
have like separate sets or is it just
like translated into no it's a separate
sense because it's hard to translate you
know I mean the
a basically rule basic rules and
techniques are the same yeah but you
know the sensitivity and culture is so
different you know yeah
detour there too oh yeah yeah it's over
there too yeah
is the comedy culture the same that like
people go to uh like oh yeah yeah oh
it's the same thing there's a comedy
clubs and all of that yes because that
of Comedy is probably the biggest
uh phenomenon in entertainment for the
past 10 years in China wow I thought it
was just like an American or English
speaking thing it was there there isn't
stand-up there wasn't stand-up comedy
uh
and then when I when I went to China
back in 2012 2013 yeah and I still
remember I tried to promote it so
sometimes I would do these small shows
in alleys in Beijing
you know it's a little uh little yard
you know we just I'll just do some sets
and there's some younger kids do
something afterwards finally this lady
who raised her hand I was so happy I was
finally they're interested you know I
said uh what kind of question do you
have she was like do you think my son
should go to America to study
it's so practical
comedy genius
it's like do you like Tylenol too
oh my God what was your answer
I'm like sure you should go go there and
do a stand-up comedy
but but then when I was first there
there's one comedy club in the city of
24 million people
and uh I I went there uh after a show
uh basically there were like five or six
guys very interested it was basically
forming a little circle right next to a
dumpster I still remember that and they
just asked me you know how the comedy
clubs have won in America what are the
open mics uh what are the professional
shows I don't like you know but now
there are at least 20 comedy clubs just
in Beijing itself wow I think it shows
every night you know it was amazing and
it's all in Chinese all in Chinese and
there's also English stand up there too
because there's a big expat Community
there and I I do English stand up there
as well but the uh crowds are so diverse
you know all the same night you have
people from South Africa England and
Netherlands and sometimes you will see
like Americans sitting right next to an
Iranian and they're laughing together I
was like wow I wish I could see this at
the U.N
except they're falling asleep at those
yeah
yeah so it's a it's a very uh it's
really but right now there's like
hundreds of clubs all over the country
here and it's really amazing damn that's
tight I didn't know it was like that who
who's the Chinese like Dave Chappelle
Chinese Dave Chappelle yeah probably you
are oh
no I'll say it for you yeah
yeah but there are a couple of guys who
made a really big day
um just and but it didn't become a thing
until 20 I would say 2020 after pandemic
started
so it's just really just the newest
budding scene out but they just put the
girls that fast yeah but it it took like
years just for people to you know hone
their skills in smaller comedy clubs wow
yeah and when I was actually I went to
China and hosted the TV show there
uh and all the TVs you have to tell us
some jokes and there was no Comedy Club
to practice my jokes
so at the time I have to go to a college
or or a company and use their conference
room and just try some jokes and that's
it you know it was really tough at the
beginning but now it's just it's
blossoming you know it's quite
interesting when did you come to the
states uh
1994. oh okay yeah his timeline is like
what the I know I know yeah yeah
yeah so that must have been a big change
because you're here
yeah while everything is developing
there and then you go back and you're
like what uh I know yeah because I just
looking back you know
the couple of times I feel that I'm
starting from zero you know Coming to
America to study is one you know because
I I was a pretty good student when I was
in China you know like
uh but then I came to America I really
because when I was in China I sometimes
I got full score on in organic chemistry
tests I came here people thought I don't
know anything about getting the
chemistry because I didn't learn it in
English I can't express myself oh it was
so painful damn that must be yes and
then gradually I got used to that in God
I actually got a PhD in Biochemistry and
then and then I started to stand up
comedy it was like starting over again
yeah it's all starting you're the
startup master I know yeah I know this
must have been so proud well fortunately
they weren't around to know this because
[Laughter]
yeah
then I moved to China it's you start
from scratch again I still remember you
know sitting at the Starbucks in Beijing
writing jokes from the first word you
know it's just and then yeah it's just
always
something like this but you know it's
kind of thrilling too you know I feel
I'm a stand-up comedian in America but
in China I feel I'm part of a movement
you know just like oh yeah that's true
yeah yeah you're International man yeah
yeah you're pioneering a whole genre in
China because they're just doing it oh
yeah yeah that's it because 2020 is like
the birth of stand-up comedy in China
well I know probably the boom you know
the birth is about 10 years already yeah
but that's still very recently
oh yeah yeah what if the movement
becomes biochem people everywhere
quitting to become Joe
[Laughter]
[Music]